both pahrump and boulder city in the
heat in the 80s this morning as well
just want you to be able to recognize
that you've been you've had too much
heat too much sun and this could happen
very quickly you know we've had a lot of
days in the 90s while we've had monsoon
rain showers and thunderstorms but heat
illness heavy sweating cramps muscle
pains that's just basically you're
overdoing it a little bit but heat
exhaustion heavy sweating dizziness
nausea vomiting it's time to come
indoors it is time to get out of the
heat cool off and get some fluids back
in you but
heat stroke that's when you have really
gone over the top if you've got a body
temperature 103 plus or if you're around
anybody displaying these symptoms
fast strong pulse and maybe not sweating
or even passing out you've got to get
them to to a doctor emergency room call
911.
we're talking about a lot of rain still
in the eastern u.s while the west is
heating up in fact across the deep south
jackson mississippi having some problems
with undrinkable water and bad water
there they've had so much
flooding in jackson that they've got a
water emergency there unreliable water
the pearl river there now infiltrating
their water system
kids are going virtual with school right
now because they don't have safe water
in the schools
so they're really having a problem
getting some nice clean safe water back
into their water system there throughout
jackson mississippi so boy from one
extreme to the other we've got fires
burning again in the west we've got too
much heat in the desert southwest the